[Musique]
madame monsieur je vous souhaite la
bienvenue dans notre émission face à la
première notre émission politique
hebdomadaire diffusée en direct le
vendredi à 14 ans sur notre site
internet et un radio le dimanche à 12
heures vie et mort du département c'est
le thème de notre émission de la semaine
puisque voici soixante douze ans le 19
mars l'assemblée nationale votée à
l'unanimité la transformation
département des quatre vieilles colonies
qui était la guadeloupe la martinique la
guyane et la réunion
le département est on le sait au moins
partiellement remplacée par la ctm la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
nous y reviendrons dans notre émission
puisque pour en parler j'ai le plaisir
de recevoir des chercheurs qui se sont
penchés sur ce sujet l'histoire de nos
institutions à travers les âges tout
d'abord l'historien marc civile un jour
il suffit aux journaux super a dit
bonjour jean claude williams qui en face
de vous et qui à ma droite le
politologue jean claude williams
professeur émérite de sciences
politiques à l'université des antilles
et de la guyane en fait excès
universités entières guyane devenue
université des antilles bonjour jean
marc thibault choc marseille il est donc
comme jeu
comment on a pu s'en apercevoir
l'anniversaire de la création du
département kahn passé quasiment
inaperçu si les vagues à 72 ans bon ce
n'est pas un chiffre rond c'est par 77 à
75 80 je ne sais pas si on en parlera
dans le futur puisqu'il n'existe plus
alors est ce qu'on peut faire un petit
rappel factuel le rappel des
circonstances dans lesquelles ce
département a été créé pour remplacer
les colonisent on se replonge à cette
décennie en arrière puisque c'est lors
de trois séances à l'assemblée nationale
et 12 13 et 15 mars 1946 que les débats
premièrement au sein de la commission de
la france d'outre-mer c'est comme ça
qu'elle semblait à l'époque et en séance
publique à l'assemblée nationale
c'est à l'issue de ces débats de ces
travaux que le département a été
officiellement fouillé puisque la loi du
19 ans la de la publication au journal
officiel fait basculer les quatre
vieilles colonies d'un statut à un autre
show claude williams oui alors je crois
que ce qu'il faut commencer par dire
c'est qu'une loi du 19 mars 1946 est en
réalité l'aboutissement d'une longue
lutte qui a commencé bien avant qu'ils
aient commencé à la fin du 19e et on
pourrait même dire d'ailleurs
j'ai entendu je sais où que finalement
avant même l'abolition de l'esclavagé la
lutte fréquence et son propre excessif
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que ces deux
dès le 19e aux alentours à la fin du
19ème qu'il ya les premières
propositions de loi et maintenant la
fois le parlementaire martiniquais et de
parlementaires européens qui demandent
qu'il faut qu'ils appelèrent unités
l'époque on y reviendra je pense que la
martinique que je connaisse
l'assimilation la grande idée c'était la
loi des simulations et par conséquent la
régulièrement régulièrement tous les
toulousains tenteront les 30 ans à peu
près le sujet revenait sur la table et
au fur et à mesure le pignon l'ensemble
de l'opinion se rassembler derrière la
revendication à l'exception notable il
est vrai surtout vers la fin après la
guerre voilà la guerre de 39 45
à l'exception notable des békés mais à
part les becquets tout le monde était il
y avait distinction droite gauche qui
existait déjà
avait complètement disparu sur cette
question il y avait une sorte
d'unanimité les mets qui n'étaient pas
d'accord pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'en réalité ils redoutaient à de
sud
on va montrer qu'ils avaient tort mais
que en définitive la loi ne se fasse
contre eux parce que bien sûr si
l'égalité était et les 8es où étaient
ils auraient à payer les charges
sociales charges patronales et il était
évidemment assez fascinant réticents
d'autant qu'il faut il expliquer que
l'intérêt que voyait la classe politique
martiniquaise et l'opinion martinique
ainsi tort- compter sur les d'opinion
c'est encore notre débat était
précisément de ferrante d'autoriser
l'égalité l'égalité réelle indice avait
quant à lui encore pas le gars
littéraire c'était ça y est notamment
l'égalité sociale c'était la grande
chose
la gauche en particulier singer
notamment c'est ce qu'ils devaient
surtout en tête
il faut pas perdre que nous sommes dans
un pays de moins de cultures agricoles
dans les conditions de vie extrêmement
pénible que le livre est maintenant le
film de joseph zobel cases-nègres rend
très bien compte des conditions lui qui
souhaite absolument misérable et c'est
par conséquent l'idée fixe de la gauche
martinique et en particulier réaliser
l'égalité
et puis il ya une question secondaire
dont on ne parle pas c'est aussi la
situation des fonctionnaires
les fonctionnaires il ya deux types de
fonctionnaires à l'époque il ya les
fonctionnaires métropolitains et puis
les fonctionnaires locaux qui ont les
clés des conditions de rémunération
particuliers qui sont très différentes
très défavorable par rapport aux autres
et tout cela fait qu'il ya une unanimité
et lorsque après la guerre les
communistes en france sont proches du
gouvernement
quand les communistes martiniquais
occupent le pouvoir
c'est une déferlante qui aboutit à la
loi le 46 alors les communistes et les
socialistes à l'époque marc ses fils
sont d'accord quoi que les socialistes
sont assez divisés entre eux j'espère
que nous aurons l'occasion de reparler
plus loin une autre fois parce que c'est
pas comme moi socialiste est assez
divisés au moins le communiste son bloc
que ce soit ici en martinique derrière
les figures les plus connus puisqu'ils
ont été élus ce cr v
by sol vous avez été élu pour ça pour
arracher la loi d'assimilation des spas
en guadeloupe également à la réunion
également avec le docteur vergès le
paiement des divergences que l'on
connaît un ancien avocat et paul vergès
oui mon verger cherchait un prénom août
en guyane ya pas de communisme et gaston
monnerville de la droite modérée pendant
un mouvement également les débats à
l'assemblée nationale pour autant ne
sont pas très unanime en tout cas il ya
beaucoup de réticences de la part du
personnel politique français refait
parisien wydad notamment de philippe
mottet qui était le ministre des dom on
va dire pour aller vite à l'époque mais
je voulais quand même revenir sur la le
processus historique qui emmène la
départementalisation douanes montrent a
beaucoup plu beaucoup plus loin ça
remonte à la révolution le pourquoi mais
qui est parlée l'assimilation c'est
boissy d'anglas dans l'indicé cac 17,94
quasiment ou fin août 80 1794 il parle
déjà de la simulation et la martinique a
connu une première départementalisation
à ce moment là il ya une qui a pas lieu
trop longtemps il n'a pas eu d'effet
nous sommes d'accord mais et puis
c'était le département de la fin de la
fête de la révolution à l'époque sur le
département a été créé à ce moment là ça
n'a pas duré longtemps que soient les
l'occupation anglaise et c est comment
il s'appelle schoelcher aussi qui est
quand même plus encore
schoelcher et puis c'est surtout parle
déjà la simulation et les premiers à
avoir parlé de décors faits commis dans
les textes qu on entre on l'a retrouvé
avoir parlé clairement deux départements
d'outre-mer seychelles cher qui dit le
mot d'un ouvrier des ministères lors
d'un prochain
oui il aimait l'idée il aimait beaucoup
d'autres idées aussi un notamment que la
carie pour être confiant si tu dois les
aimer l'idée l'assimilation c'est quand
même cher qui la porte et il ya une
première pas départementalisation mais
la marge de l'assimilation commence
vraiment avec la seconde du public
quand la seconde république met en place
un certain nombre de lois après
l'abolition esclavage et je crois que
fondamentalement
l'idée assimilationniste né à ce moment
du fait qu' on a une abolition de
l'esclavagé qui est complètement
différente de celle des anglais et le
sel des espagnols parce que qu'est ce
qui se passe à la fin la bullies
l'abolition de l'esclavagé à la
française on va dire donne quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas dans les autres munitions
dans la citoyenneté française et je
crois que là c'est un point fondamental
des u16 et à la peut dire dans certains
écrits je crois que là c'est fondamental
et c'est ça qui met la marche vers la
simulation parce que tous les tous les
anciens esclaves deviennent des citoyens
des citoyens électeurs venant des
citoyens et le sol mais devant des
citoyens de seconde zone
soyaux si on recule avec le retour de
napoléon iii ou pouvoir ayant réussi que
ce recul est né le le tout la lutte des
anciens esclaves et de leurs descendants
du première génération post
abolitionnistes
c'est de conquérir cette égalité
cette assimilation qui si l'égalité
l'égalité est synonyme d'assimilation et
l'a d'ailleurs la fête du tri soutenir
le montre 1935 1935
enfin il ya tout un pays qui est qui
marche un point de détail vous dites que
par rapport aux colonies étrangler ce
britannique qui l'ont l'abolition à lui
en 1833 aux colonies espagnoles beaucoup
plus tard comme où il a entassé 1800
5186 à peu près avec un plot processus
puis à la loi moore et enfin porto rico
d'abord puis tu baves donc la
citoyenneté britannique ou espagnol
n'est pas accordée aux anciens esclaves
libérés
non non ne n'y a pas de citoyens et
citoyennes 2006 le quan ho c'est comme
ça ils n'ont pas les mêmes droits non
pas qu il ne l'est pas il n'est pas
utile surtout il n'est pas écrit dans
les textes abolitionniste anglais ou
espagnol que ils deviennent des citoyens
à part entière anglais ou espagnol et je
crois que là c'est un prêt fondamentales
qui nous distingue dans la caraïbe jean
louis allamèle même même pas seulement
la garrigue je crois que précisément ce
qu'il faut souligner aussi c'est que en
réalité la france dans ce qu'on appelle
les vient épauler les cas il revient
évolué
il faut en parler parce que c'est pas du
tout indifférent les quatre vieilles
colonies ou d'un traitement différent
les autres pourquoi indicateurs des
colonies juste un procès mais la mère
judy quinn on voit pourquoi ça c'est
interdit
parce que ce sont les premières à avoir
été colonisés et par conséquent aussi si
le non dit arrêtez civilisé à voir et
bien sûr avant et et civilisée car c'est
car c'est ça la question est beaucoup
d'ailleurs de martiniquais guadeloupéens
de réunir dans les argumentaires qu'ils
vont avancer pour réclamer la simulation
vous prenez pas comme ces sauvages
d'afrique car les autres ce sont les
africains et on entend bien se démarquer
2 il n'est pas normal que nous grâce à
la bienveillance des maîtres et les
gouvernants nous avons été civilisé n'a
accédé à la situation alors que les
autres sont restés dans dans la forêt
n'est ce pas dans son corps ils ne sont
pas mûrs ils ne seront jamais des
risques et j'ai dit ce que l'on
attendait donc c'est cela pourrait
distinguer des autres et par conséquent
il n'est pas normal qu'on ait le même
statut que les autres vous avez c'est un
peu sur la continuité du discours de 17
vous avez commencé un processus il faut
aller au terme du processus et le terme
du processus si nous accordez vous avez
raison fruit de ces nous accorder la
citoyenneté
adacore plus alors cette particularité
est extraordinaire c'est que dans un
premier temps en tout cas
lorsqu'il ya une coïncidence une
correspondance entre l'abolition et le
suffrage universel l'accès ou suffrages
il ya celle qu'on les aime évidemment
pas question pour les femmes est me
donner cette situation ubuesque que et
des gens sortent de l esclavage avec
évidemment le déficit de connaissance du
savoir l'évocation de ce congrès est
brutalement brutalement qu'ils accèdent
à ou droits de vote tout je me permets
de vous et tout de suite c'est à dire
que l'abolition est accordé
et effective le 22 mai comme on sait un
mais et on vote en septembre et dont il
ya tout un travail parce que l'espagne
n'avait pas de nom il fallait leur
donner un nom on fait tout le travail
qui fait entre mai et septembre mais qui
est pas suffisant pour donner plein et
le 30 août en martinique le oui mais là
bas ce qui est étonnant dans ce cas vous
dites là c'est que en fait cette
assimilation devenir des citoyens
français comme tout autre et beaucoup et
beaucoup plus anciennes compenser tout à
l'heure j'ai rendu l'âme vous parliez de
bicêtre emploi me 7,7 se distinguent
est-il de celle cher parce qu'il n'était
pas au dépens sur le même plan sur la
sueur n'était pas d'accord si on si
cette idée là oui alors biographie lyon
va pas parce que c'est trop trop
longuement parce qu'on peut faire une
émotion non l'important c'est que depuis
cet été un mulâtre dans une société faut
pas l'oublier qui était une société
complètement il rare chez willow sur wii
en face à ces seuils légaux oui
pour l'anecdote mais dans la réalité
c'était un mulâtre que tu es négocions
et qui est évidemment comme tous les
mulâtres de l'époque avec l'idée c'était
d'être considérés comme les égaux des
blancs à tel point d'ailleurs que en
1822 si j'ai bonne mémoire il va
participer dans l'ajout du carbet à une
action répressive contre démarre au
quart des esprits alors même que sa mère
est mourante et d'ailleurs il va après
le regretté très très vivement et il va
être impliqué bissett va être un beau
être impliqué dans une affaire de
diffusion d'un document qui insistait
sur le fait que les mulâtres était
maltraitée choc la révolte ont été
maltraités mais ils semblent nombreux
l'égalité exemple c'est la question de
l'égalité on lisait on n'est pas au jeu
aurait on réclame d'avoir d'être
considérés comme des blancs il ya des
choses qu'on pour les libres bien sûr on
élève notre liberté a des limites
par exemple il ya des lieux que les
mulâtres ne peuvent pas fréquenter ou
pas les mêmes conditions que les blancs
il ya des professio et ne peuvent pas
exercer alors je dis pour rigoler mais
c'est la vérité qui ne peut pas être
barbier parce qu'évidemment il
le rasoir rasoir peut déraper et puis ne
pouvait pas par exemple non plus être
être de nos terres parce que le notaire
accès aux secrets de famille les femmes
et au président s'il ne pouvait pas
s'habiller dans les mêmes tissus les
beaux tissus que les que les blancs
parce qu'évidemment les femmes
mulâtresse étaient très recherchées par
les blancs si en plus elle avait dû vous
avez c'était foutu
par conséquent il ya eu toutes ses aises
tout c'est interdit par conséquent ce
document dé ces sont les interdits et 17
et considérer qu'il n'est pas l'auteur
du texte mais il est considéré comme le
principal propagateur du texte et il va
être très sévèrement punis et ça être un
déclic dans sa tête
à partir de là il va comprendre qu'elle
a fait fausse route qu'il peut pas se
désolidariser des esclaves et que par
qu'il va être le premier à veauchette
cher à réclamer l'abolition de
l'esclavagé va publier une petite revue
qui s'appelle de ces lignes est enseigné
à paris a paraît il on l'espère a vu des
colonies et dans laquelle il va plaider
inlassablement pour l'abolition les
scandales et lui dès le début alors ses
huit lits il faut il faut il faut
l'assimilation mais dans sa tête
assimilation c'est égalité voilà c'est
pourquoi on est la toute puissance des
planteurs des békés également donc est
ce que ces débats politiques que l'on a
dans la colonie ou dans le petit milieu
des abolitionnistes à paris ne transpire
pas véritablement dans les cercles du
pouvoir parisien il faut attendre la
monarchie de juillet c'est à dire les
années quasiment 1840 pourquoi enfin le
personnel politique français parisien
s'intéresse de très près à la
transformation nécessaire du régime
économique politique administratif
institutionnels dans les colonies donc
ses fils oui ou oui et non c'est à dire
que et puis la france était un petit peu
en retard par rapport à l'angleterre
c'est il ya aussi ça il ya aussi sur la
scène internationale la france l'a
traité tabou dit depuis 1815 enfin bon
il ya tout
il ya tout un contexte aussi même si
elle continue clandestinement oui mais
tout bien tout ce contexte mêlés aux
envois des sections dans même oui le
bateau
elle est officiellement aboli au congrès
de vienne en 1815 et donc mais il y a
surtout le fait que le contexte
économique change aussi parce qu'on a
comme le sucre comme ans est en crise
une crise sucrière
il y à aussi il faut un autre il faut de
nouveau de nouveaux paradigmes
économiques et je pense que c'est tout
ça qui mélangent et puis il ya aussi
l'action des esclaves qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'on a peut-être à une certaine
époque un peu
[Musique]
sous-estimer estimé mais qui est qui et
quand même là et puis il ya quand même
aussi un certain nombre de grandes
banques et qui sont pour l'abolition de
l'esclavagé économique c'est pas
forcément d un film en partie
philanthropiques mais pour des desseins
économique parce que et puis il ya les
négociants enfin bon il ya tout un
contexte tout ça ça bouillonne et puis
ce qui nous va nous amener
et puis le contexte aussi l'arrêtera il
ya la betterave voilà c'est ça et puis
il ya du sucre de betterave prend le pas
sur le sucre africains en découdre et
puis elle a aussi le contexte politique
en france
en france c'est les évolutionnaire de
les révolutionnaires de 1848 qui dès
février puisque la révolution en france
a eu lieu en février et qui dès février
sont sur cette longueur savent comme qui
vont à beaulieu les esclavages
d'ailleurs content quand la révolution
éclate chez cheikh est à dacca aussi
grâce à lui le succès du projet du
sénégal pour imposer pratiquement arago
l'aragon françois ragot qui était le
ministre de la marine et des colonies
qui a été quasiment obligé de mettre
qu'il était d'accord sur l'idée mais ces
chercheurs qui le combat de l'urgence
nous sommes dans face à la première
si en martinique la première avec
aujourd'hui le professeur jean claude
willem que vous venez d'entendre et
marque ses fils nous parlons de
l'évolution des institutions martinique
à travers les âges à partir de la nive
et ans et entre guillemets de la
création du département qui a disparu
depuis
et donc nous tous lecteurs nous avons
longuement parlé tous les deux de cette
idée de la simulation la
départementalisation parfois il ya eu
confusion entre les deux cette idée de
l'égalité des droits sociaux puis des
droits politiques
est-ce que
la formule du département qui a été
acquise en 1946 n'arrive pas un peu trop
tard dans l'histoire par rapport à ce
qu'on vient de dire puisqu'il a fallu
quasiment un siècle on peut dire ça
c'est une longue bataille d'un siècle
qui a amené à l'application de ce soit
de ce désir de cette volonté
j'attends de lire oui trop tôt ou trop
tard j'en sais rien aujourd'hui beaucoup
disent que précisément le grand reproche
qu'on pourrait faire à crc loi rater le
rendez-vous de 46 ça me paraît une
lecture très hâtive de l'histoire et
c'est à dire puisqu'à la grande question
sa question du lieu aujourd'hui encore
du statut politique on n'est que si ces
aires en 46
compte tenu de la popularité était la
sienne avait posé la question
d'indépendance à ce moment là la
martinique aurait obtenu la guadeloupe
pour tirer les parents ce qui me paraît
de vue de l'esprit et par conséquent non
c'est pas une question qu'aujourd'hui
alors certainement la situation qui
n'aurait connu aujourd'hui serait bien
pire que celle d'haïti d'aujourd'hui
c'est ça la réalité des choses parce que
précisément il faut bien comprendre
l'histoire s'est passé c'est pas le
fantasme
j'insistais tout à l'heure sur les
conditions réelles du vie qu'il y avait
à l'époque
et puis j'ai essayé de mettre aussi
l'accent sur le fait
ce raisonnement l'idée des gens c'était
l'égalité la volonté profonde du peuple
toutes tendances confondues je le répète
c'est pas c'est l'une des rares fois
dans l'histoire de nos pays qu'il ait eu
une telle unanimité qu'est une telle
unanimité et par conséquent les
collectionner thème pas du tout réunies
pour que la question de l'indépendance
la pesée je répète d'ailleurs jaj
précise que les pays africains
notez que que 15 en dix ans après même
effectivement 15 ans après et par
conséquent l'idée même le la question
même mais n'était dans l'esprit de
personne s opposent à paris la vraie
question qui se pose est contrairement à
ce qui se faisait dans les colonies
britanniques parce que la colonisation
les pétés de même nature jean-marc avec
la même
collation dit vrai le vrai débat c'est
le débat qui va opposer en martinique
césaire est sévère dans ses salles
si c'était le dernier maire de débattre
tous tous les bus évidemment d'accord
pour l'assimilation c'est comme ça qu'on
travaille mais sévère et est partisan de
ce qu'il va appeler une assimilation
mitigé tandis que césaire est parti lors
d'une simulation totale là mitigé sur
avec les socialistes et ses airs avec
les communistes mériaux pas puisque ça
ne st pas se soient pas des combats
personnifiée
oui mais s'est sensiblement dégradé les
figures retrouver ces deux figures de
proue d'un côté chez sévère négociation
est pas mais pourquoi ils mitigé c'est
très intéressant parce que précisément
les colonies avait cette tâche cet
avantage d'avoir une réelle liberté
fiscale et financière est sévère victor
sévère vite c'est vers 10 heures il faut
que nous ayons l'égalité certes mais que
le continuant à bénéficier de ces
avantages fiscaux et financiers et ceux
de ce droit dérogatoire l'escouade et
durera du raca c'est un débat qui est au
cours actuel complètement complètement
actuelle est là et c'est ça la vraie
différence
et puis alors fini des corps portait
aussi
c'est un vrai débat on y reviendra
aujourd'hui encore la question par
conséquent est pesé et lorsqu'on dit par
exemple que le disco les trois ou cinq
liberté de crg passionnant parlera plus
tard ce qui était novateur c'est une
erreur totale
c'est une régression de la réalité parce
que c'est à ce moment là en 1978 qui
s'aperçoit que le ceser s'aperçoit que
que ces ados mal à vous allez moi phase
avec le professeur oui vous avez
prononcé le nom du docteur paul
valentino qui était donc médecin
généraliste en guadeloupe qui est devenu
député socialiste qui était l'un des
leaders socialistes guadeloupe et là
j'avais une divergence avec les
communistes en guadeloupe et qui s'est
retrouvé dans les débats de la
commission qui a préparé la loi de
départementalisation est ainsi qu à la
tribune et lui de valentino disait mais
attention avec bon nombre de socialistes
martiniquais et y compris notre sévère
attention nous glisse quand nous les
élus locaux de perdre du pouvoir le
pouvoir que nous avons sous le régime
colonial
parce que si on devient comme un nouveau
département comme tout autre la gironde
où là que sais-je encore la lozère il y
aura un préfet et qui aura plus de
pouvoir que les actuels gouverneur et
nous risquons d'être mis de côté
l'histoire apparemment il y aura donné
raison
les points forts qui font tiquer c'est
que avant la loi de leva de l'a46 qu il
ya déjà les conseils généraux en effet
les jours existe déjà il précisément au
les prérogatives réelles notamment
profit cgc des droits doit intervenir en
amont les pas plus que c'est le droit
d'amender les lois de doigts jeu
reviendra tout à l'heure à leur vente
valentino est ce que dans les textes que
vous avez étudié pour faire cette
histoire des institutions puisque je
rappelle mais je veux les ont rendus à
l'émission que vous êtes l'auteur de
lundi seuls livres en tout cas très
récent sur l'histoire des religions
évolution institutionnelle et politique
des antilles le cas de la martinique
chez ibis rouge publiée en 2003 il ya
déjà un très bon niveau alors le docteur
valentino qui est la figure de proue de
ce qui compte est l'assimilation
intégral l'assimilation total mais il
est pris les suivants sa part le
gouvernement parce qu'on doutait aussi
qu'ils honnissent de la france
d'outre-mer la fonderie philippe le
ministre des finances des finances ils
sont pas tout à fait d'accord
d'ailleurs l'article 3 de la loi de
départementalisation a eu et a dû être
modifié c'est parce que sous la pression
de l'est monnerville et de ceux qui
voulaient la simulation totale et donc
valentino lui il met en garde contre
contre certains ce type de choses et
l'ordre nouveau qui va qui va qui va
arriver après et vous le faites vous
fait de le dire fait bien de le dire que
le préfet sera pas le gouverneur et
césaire tout au long des dix ans qui
suivent la colonne à la
départementalisation oil de ses salles à
l'assemblée nationale de défendre cette
assimilation total et même un moment
donné d'été a pris d'interpeller le
le ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque
en lui disant prenez garde je crois que
c'est aux 46 46 47 donc très tôt il lui
dit faites attention je le nom du du
ministre de l'intérieur de l'époque me
place des fêtes
faites attention parce que si vous ne
l'appliqué pas globalement je le dis de
façon quand il résumé oui lui mais est
ce qu'il a dit parce qu'il le disait
avec beaucoup plus de postes que moi et
de fait attention parce que si vous
n'appliquez pas l'assimilation total il
va arriver ce qui ne se reconnaît pas
aux antilles se trouve connaît pas la
réunion ce qu'on connaît pas la guyane
c'est un mouvement nationaliste dont il
a dit il
il a déjà compris que si on n'applique
pas l'assimilation total il y aura ce
problème de nationalisme qui va qui va
ce qui va surgir un peu comme dans les
colonies avoisinants et aux latinos
n'est pas allé jusque là quand même il
n'a pas germé ce qu'ils sont là disait
ceux qui étaient contre une assimilation
total c'est terrible et c'était de
garder un certain nombre de prérogatives
et au nom de ce qu'on appelle à une
époque qu'on appelle plus comme ça
aujourd'hui des spécificités qu'on avait
un cave était acquise sous le régime
colonial il faut dire les choses comme
elles sont parce que toute la troisième
république va mettre le peut-être que le
drame de la troisième république ça a
été de ne pas avoir de constitution en
fait véritablement il ya que des lois
constitutionnelles et il n'a pas su
fixer un statut pour les colonies pour
l'expo les vieilles colonies pour ça
qu'on appelle les vielles colonne et et
je pense que n'ayant pas pu le fixe et
ben
la vieille revendication
assimilationniste d'égalité parfaite a
gagné 1,46 ce que je vois moi c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de volonté politique
c'est pas une question une absence je
crois qu'en réalité il ya une pression
forte et le gone en français a cru qu'il
allait finalement accepté formellement
et qu'il allait jouer la montre c'est
d'ailleurs très vite ce que certains
membres du gouvernement certains préfets
même au tout début le respect
d'attention les gens vous pour le
sérieux et si vous ne tenez pas vos
promesses
on lira vers les plus graves difficultés
c'est ce qui s'est passé et c'est comme
ça que au fur et à mesure au fur et à
mesure les choses ont évolué et que la
départementalisation est remise en cause
et c'est peut-être ce legend d'accord je
marque
l'occasion de dire que césaire très vite
très tôt aux 46 césaire distingue
départementalisation et assimilation en
effet comme l'indiqué quoi ce télégramme
parlent de leur histoire pour les
classes laborieuses assimilation à qui
il fallait aller vite c'est un
télégramme est ce que c'est de là qu'est
née la culture aussi oui on s'est très
vite il fallait la simulation
c'est une doctrine politique c'est une
doctrine un courant de pensée la
départementalisation c'est un statut et
le statut les papilles l'upa savez après
val d'yerres très vite le statut ce
qu'on appelle à tort la loi
d'assimilation qui est en fait une loi
de départementalisation militairement et
10 et une loi de départementalisation
c'est-à-dire un statut et le statut est
inscrit sous le signe du prg un quart et
du révocables par conséquent on peut
changer le statut le courant de pensée
c'est autre chose
et à partir de là effectivement il va
toujours toujours par les deux
départements et la possibilité par
conséquent de changer de steak alors
province
revenant en arrière rapidement bronze
elle s'est spécialisée la question
j'accorde où je me disais
d'ailleurs que même si nous étions
colonies il y avait tout de même un
conseil général est ce qu on peut
rappeler les conditions dans lesquelles
le conseil général se met en place en
martinique en 1827 et à peu près à la
même époque en guadeloupe un peu plus
tard en guyane et à la réunion
mais le contexte dans lequel qui ne
ressemble pas à celui qui est appuyée
sur le la métropole commises à l'époque
mais c'est pas le même conseil général
et c'est un conseil général qui est qui
inspirait du conseil des comptes des
conseils un peu qu'ils ont coexisté un
peu avant c'est à dire de régler les
affaires politiques
mais ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui une
grande autonomie de deux décisions sur
les sols par exemple un exemple concret
le conseil général de la martinique
c'est lui qui met en place les premiers
avant avant l'hexagone les premières loi
sur l'enseignement veulent c'est gratuit
sur les coûts complémentaires fédérales
oui certain nombre de lois qui sont qui
sont qu'ils sont passés c'est pas
seulement une chambre d'enregistrement
c'est une chambre qui qui qui qui est
vraiment dans le pays alors que mon bien
sûr on peut critiquer certaines
décisions qui ont pu être prises mais il
avait une totale pas totale mais une
grande liberté et pour refaire un
certain nombre de choses - vous l'avez
bien sur le régalien rester au
gouverneur tout ce qui était militaire
restait au gouverneur
mais tout ce qui concerne l
administration des communes
l'administration globale de la colonie
comme on disait en gros travaux tout ça
ça va faire exceptionnel octroi de mer
qui permettait de financer le vive voix
la tabaski si on dit dans la colonie un
héritage que nous avons ne s'était pas
mais même plus loin c'est cet octroi de
mer qui qui ont monté à 595 m alors
d'affaires avant le conseil général même
s'il n'était pas élu sur la base que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui nom du suffrage
universel avec tous les personnes
majeures qui peuvent être élus électeurs
aient lieu lectrices là c'était pas du
tout le cas les pontons puisque c'est un
sioux c'était une suite en quelque sorte
au début ces trois organes qui la
cultiveront s'était pas c'était pas
c'était pas la démocratie non plus
la démocratie telle que nous la
concevons aujourd'hui mais il y avait
quand même des élections et puis c'était
et puis en 1827
il y avait une grande part la majorité
de la population de voter parce qu'elle
est encore esclaves
voilà donc ça il faut le succès vous le
vernis ne s'est pas laissée pas le même
canton du conseil général il faut pas
faire la profusion avec le général qu'on
a depuis on a eu depuis quand mais les
compétences sont les premiers temps soit
là c'était les compétences qui change
qui est qui était beaucoup plus
important oui puisque le conseil général
prend la suite des différents organes
qui j'ai dit j'irai dirigeait la colonie
que ce soit le conseil coloniale le
conseil supérieur le conseil souverain
ils ont eu des appellations différentes
il faut dire que c'est une institution
ne trouve pas dans les autres colonies
moi je soupçonne quand même un peu le
boulot les gouvernements français de
l'époque et puis d'une certaine
continuité d'avoir voulu administrer les
vieilles colonies un peu comme comme
l'angleterre administrer ses colonies
moi je pense que c'est un bon petit
pessac avait d ailleurs gérer vos
affaires vous même qu'à paris
d'administration direct pendant très
longtemps du gouvernement central part
dans ces colonies l'entouré les quatre
vieilles colonies non non enfin il ya
une administration centrale mais le
gouverneur a vraiment pour l'occupation
coloniale c'est à dire assurer que le
commerce se passe bien et puis assurer
la l'intégrité et on va dire un physique
qu'il n'y a pas de débarquement
d'anglais en seconde il y avait une très
large autonomie à combien les syriens
auraient planteurs les colons les
commerçants les militaires et les
fonctionnaires pour la plupart venant
venant dans l'annexé vian est invité
pour quelques années
donc pour re tour dans notre période
contemporaine le département acquis en
1946 très rapidement il est critiqué par
des communistes ou d'autres alors que
c'est eux qui avaient obtenu qu il qu'il
existe en 1946 même si ce n'était pas
les premiers historiquement à l'avant
souhaité mais très rapidement le
département les moisissures à à décevoir
c'est l'espoir déçu ils avaient beaucoup
investi nous y croyait beaucoup les
communes aussi convoyé fondant beaucoup
mais il est vrai que sa conscience c'est
que à l'époque j'ai dit tout à l'heure
les communistes en france étaient
proches du pouvoir n'était pas jouable
étaient très proches du pouvoir
or les communistes finalement vont se
séparer fallait la question du livre
entrer dans l'opposition gérard guenat
partir la guerre froide et va commencer
c'est un vrai que c'est important aussi
et par conséquent les communiste
martiniquais était très très très proche
et c'est presque un euphémisme
les communes se fendre qui étaient des
communistes français à l'époque permet
simplement vont être très déçus et ils
vont plus calquer leur position sur
celle des communistes français dont il
montre et ils vont entrer dans
l'opposition
et comme les promesses tardent à se
concrétiser et en faisant beaucoup pas
se concrétiser au fur et à mesure
indiqué la position à 16 heures mais ce
sera aussi celle des communistes en
général à l'écouter c'est plus possible
puisque vous ne voulez plus de loups
cccm euros et sucre puisque tu ne veux
pas de moi m'a coûté mon rêve c'est si
tu me dis que tu vas plus gentils avec
moi je vais rester
c'est rigolo mais c'est ça c'est ça
cet état d'esprit on menace de partir
avec le secret espoir qu'on n'aura pas à
partir et c'est un jeu comme ça qu'il a
qui va se faire mais ce qu'il faut dire
aussi jean marc tardif c'est que en
réalité contrairement scoop donc 1946 ne
crée pas c'est pas c'est pas un choc
c'est par il n'y a pas de vrai
changement dangereux mais il n'y a pas
un changement un changement évidemment
notamment même si cela prend du temps et
lois sociales commencent à se mettre en
place les dispositions avec deux points
de conclure ses discussions concernant
les fonctionnaires elle aussi se met en
place mais la martinique
naître une colonie dans son
fonctionnement fed et connaît le
potentiel une colonie le rythme le
rythme coloniale spdr le changement
véritable
c'est pour ça que je dis que lorsqu'on
dit que 46 et une étape décisive c'est
pas si sûr que ça c'est juridiquement
l'étape décisive
c'est symboliquement l'état décisive
concrètement c'est pas un tapissier
l'étape décisive le basculement
c'est bien après 58e on peut lire la
période entre 58 et 60
c'est ça qui compte d'ailleurs qui
bascule mais bien sûr pour les profanes
1958 c'est ce que vous allez voir
mais pourquoi sa fille à un changement
ils sont six mais pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui se passe à ce moment là
qu'elle les événements rupert buteurs
tels que l'espace qui font que
l'économique et surtout pendant les dix
ans qui séparent les douze ans on va
dire que c'est pas là et ses yeux le dit
très bien les saisir le combat de ces
entre 46 58 6 de faire appliquer cette
départementalisation ci de là vraiment
de la faire appliquer elodie
pratiquement chaque fois arrivé à
l'assemblée nationale il
il a des mots aux questions au
gouvernement partout il
il insiste sur le fait que la
départementalisation est mal appliquée
donc et il se sent un peu berner un peu
un peu un peu un peu floués par cette
départementale à simulation totale
départementalisation qu'il avait demandé
et qui est qu'ils voient pas les
fouilles et donc moi je pense que à ce
moment là il est il est dans une
situation il est mal à l'aise quand ils
voient bien devant ses électeurs parce
qu'il faut avait promis un peu plus de
moins de misère à la misère ou la ccsa
le quotidien le quotidien moi je pense
de 2,6 et à ce moment là et il faut
quand même souligner qu' il n'est pas
il est il est dans le pape quoi ils
voient les gens et chaque fois qu'il qui
lui qui va à l'assemblée nationale c'est
simplement pour demander mais
effectivement le basculement je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est vraiment 58
quand le général de gaulle arrive au
pouvoir
d'ailleurs saisir du ch ont confiance il
lui fait confiance il est pas gaulliste
pur mais il pense que c'est un grand
homme et cetera je pense qu'il a
vraiment pas prête pas de la
dénomination avoué mais je pense parce
que c'est selon se câlinent le docteur
aliker dans une interview à 2006 on lui
demandait qui était le plus grand homme
politique français pour lui du 20e
siècle sont sans hésiter il a dit que
c'était à eux de golf donc je pense
qu'il a quand même une admiration pour
de gaulle pour le résistant et puis on
est dans le contexte guerres d'algérie
et d'indochine
on est dans un contexte dans les années
40 où les colonies s'émancipe et je
pense que quelques pas au coin de sa
tête il a peut-être parce que je suis
pas là dans le coin de la tête de sésame
enfin que la signe que la simulation la
départementalisation pouvait être une
forme de décolonisation s'esquisse les
recrues c'était la décolonisation à la
française c'est ce qu'elle a cru
longtemps alors 2-2 de remarques rapide
la première 16h à fait à une confiance
totale en grande confiance avait
confiance en jean de gaulle et iéna
lecteurs que rapporte victor sablé dans
la transformation des îles de l'est de
la france en amérique
victor sa grille 1 10e 6 alors césaire
sur la 5ème république n'est avec la
constitution
au point de départ c'est compliqué pour
de gaulle il n'est pas du tout sûr de
gagner un référendum tarifaire n'est pas
sûr de gagner
et par conséquent il est convaincu que
ça peut se jouer en outre-mer ici en
martinique le ppm vient de vient de
naître
c'est la confusion aristide mauger bon
frère le cdr guéant était l'homme fort
du ppm laissant clairement dit non
les communistes également le couple est
également arrêtée chez elle à brest muet
la réunion c est resté muet dans un
premier tri se taire il est à paris à
l'époque et communication des tacoma
sauf qu'il est à paris est le général de
gaulle lui fait dire devenir le voit à
matino puisque à l'époque le giro noël
est pas encore prêts publics et les
premiers ministres il est présent du
conseil lait les prix dans les conseils
et il le convoque en même temps que
savent les sables elle n'assiste pas
l'entrevue et sablé rapporte que c'est
que ces airs va voir le général de
gaulle un peu inquiet pas très gentils
sont espacées et il voit un césar
souriant il le visage illuminé
complètement admiratif il a été fasciné
fasciné par des rumeurs je pense facile
et par l'école et puis comme nous l a
compris le coût de gaulle a remis une
couche en faisant venir ici maroc quand
intellectuelle que c'était le pire est
vraiment qui était l'homme de confiance
zone de confiance de lire de la culture
et alors que le pépin par la voix de mme
auger avait dit en votre nom
cesari on a acquis des assurances des
franchises les franchises au vote oui ça
se passe en images ont incendié huit
jours le premier rideau vie jours amende
à hauteur d'homme plutôt le ppm et sur
la ligne des communistes ville de
guadeloupe 2 de la réunion également des
quatrièmes justin catayée du parti
socialiste guyanais qui disent nous
votons non ne voulons pas de cette
constitution parce que nous n'obtenons
pas l'égalité des droits
et donc c'était une sorte de chantage
malraux et vient ici à la réunion puis
en guyane martinique pour rassurer et en
pente la décision d'aider ces chefs
politiques
je ne veux pas dire autonomiste à
l'époque le mot no non non non le pull
de mai en tout cas de ceux qui vouent
une deuxième de ce qu'il a appelé à
voter non à mon avis d au sein d'une
même pas là l'essentiel je lis
rapidement tout à l'heure c'est
l'économique
c'est à partir de ce moment-là ce à
partir de la fin des années 50 que
l'économie devient on est bien sûr mais
c'est cela c'est cela la marque jusqu'à
présent c'était une colonie au sens
classique et à partir de monoculture de
la canne creney axial comme dance à
disparaître
on entre dans le cycle de lave de la
banale mais surtout de l'associé
consommation elle commence là c'est à
sonnac on commença à bétonner les champs
de canne part au prix fort
jean vous avez porté des bois tout à
fait importer des voitures et la
consommation
la batterie change complètement de
visage c'est à ce moment là que les
campagnes se vident et que césaire à
fort de france bricoles comme il peut
pour accueillir des gens à valga trézel
etc
c'est cela il ya un changement total et
c'est évidemment à partir de là que les
idées évoluent et que l'idée d'autonomie
en particulier voisin le joueur est en
fait comme vous l'avez dit marx et fils
2 go là que s'est accru que de gaulle à
les comprendre que les franchises allait
permettre effectivement d'avoir des
libertés d'avoir un début d'autonomie et
loulou ne s'est pas prononcé voilà il
quand il s'aperçoit que c'est d'ailleurs
au voyage ce goal 64 le fan le fameux
bug qui lui est donnée à prendre en
compte les rappeler pour ceux qui berce
était en 62 si c'était le 64 le passage
de de gaulle à la menthe inique qui
était aussi populaire de crs étaient des
gens sur la savane je crois qu'ils
allaient encore il ya des images qui
existent de données plat qui montre
vraiment une ferveur populaire sociale
quand vous êtes français etc et de gold
unis bubba césaire lui demande j'oublie
les mozart un bon bain qu'en est il de
ces dossiers de ces franchises dont nous
avions parlé quatre ans plus tôt et 2 go
ludique entre les entre l'europe et
l'amérique
il n'ya que poussière et qu'on ne
construit pas des états sur des
poussières
c'est une formule très gaullienne et
s'était essayé à ce moment là il n'y
aurait pas eu de de franchir face aux
yachts est octroyé un peu plus pour
gérer la
le pays est il vain il va pas le faire
tout de suite mais puisque c'est quoi
mieux au premier congrès du pic au
troisième congrès du ppm dans 67 que le
mot d'ordre d'autonomie vraiment
prononcé
donc il ya une lente ça fait très mal et
oisive et oui il ya une autre maturation
de cesser toute autonomie
mais par exemple - embryon de mouvements
indépendantistes qui commence à naître
aussi en effet avec la sphère de l'eau
jamais que c'était là qui n'est vraiment
pas le même là même qui n'a vraiment pas
le lam les mêmes options bien passé nous
non plus deux illuminés racines non plus
que le col l'idée d'autonomie
nous sommes quasiment arrivés au terme
de l'émission nous avons vu rapidement
que le statut des colonnes de la
martinique a changé colonies pour mirage
d'essaimage troisième âge département ça
veut dire que demain il peut encore
changer
l'implant de william sa stature on peut
le penser sauf que sauf que je crois que
aujourd'hui mais même si le discours
officiel de 2,2 beaucoup court 6
continue à être qu'il faut changer
même l epa nantis cet avis moi je crois
que en réalité les questions la question
essentielle ne se pose pas vraiment ces
termes elle il me semble pas je crois
que la majorité des martiniquais se
satisfait pour l'essentiel de la
situation actuelle est comme ça dans une
situation que j'appelle moi de
dépendance consentis nous sommes
d'accord pas les bras nous nous
intégrons la dépense et pourquoi la ccc
iconoclaste de ce que je dis c'est que
le classer comme suit ce que je crois je
crois vraiment ce que je crois vraiment
c'est que en réalité nous avons toute
une série de le coup dont les conditions
de vie qui sont les conditions de vie
qui sont comparables parfait supérieur à
certains pays d'europe et notamment je
parle à certaines régions françaises
il faut dire les choses clairement et
les martiniquais en sont conscients et
les martiniquais n'ont pas du tout envie
de perdre ces avantages cela et ils se
rendent bien alors que cela se fait
évidemment au détriment
une semaine un certain type de liberté
encore que depuis quelques temps le
niveau culturel
il y à une des avancées réelles
le créole maintenant est acceptée
couramment il ya un bac une épreuve
créole qui a capté ce créole je crois
une à gré du creal par conséquent la
musique traditionnelle on la joue
surtout les zones touchées par tous par
conséquent la résistance la résistance
trouvait son ancrage dans l'affirmation
identitaire
or de ce point de vue je ne dis pas que
tout est fait mais tous ont beaucoup
évolué et par conséquent une sorte
d'accommodement regardez les dernières
élections
je ne parle même pas de l'abstention qui
camus sens qui a du sens l'abstention a
du sens mais c'est pas les mêmes raisons
de l'acte que l'abstention le
traditionnel compte d'abord l'abstention
du sort mais aussi regarder ce qui s'est
passé finalement on les martiniquais
dans leur majorité ont accepté de mettre
en place une équipe qui avait
précisément comme comme base un accord
de lessio on ne touche pas aux
institutions et du coup elle a souhaité
jeudi salle portable est passé coptes
extraordinaire le pmn qui paraissait en
retard idéologiquement par rapport au
mime va se retrouver l'institution extra
l'ordre de finalement apparaître comme
celui qui veut renverser la table alors
que marie jeanne en homme sage passe
accord avec mon plaisir voilà puis on
voit bien ce que ça donnait ça donne
aujourd'hui une situation non pas
simplement l'immobilisme mais une
situation de régression alors oui pour
terminer ma vous avez envie de moi ce
que je pense fondamentalement c'est que
mon statut n'est pas figé et je crois
que
on n'a pas parlé de cette partie de
l'histoire de l'histoire du passé qui
qui qui le début la fin des années 2000
on va dire depuis la déclaration de
bastia qui a fait cas beaucoup fait
changer les choses et qui a surtout
changé juridiquement les choses qui a
changé l'article l'article 73 a beaucoup
changé a changé il faisait trois lignes
au début il ya une multitude de
possibilités et les martiniquais sont
devenus des constitutionnalistes et
méritent aujourd'hui fuite depuis le
référendum de 2010 tout le monde sait ce
que pratiquement ce que si colérique 72
73 74 du cotton eyed joe diffie le nomme
cette consultation pour aller vie et je
crois que on arrive quand même à une
maturité des gens et comme vous le dites
moi je crois que nos habitudes de
consommation ont déjà ans déjà déjà voté
pour nous sur ce principe là maintenant
il faut rester là dedans
vous restez dans le cadre français même
si on ne sait pas on n'est pas au caire
sur la forme à donner à cette à cette
institution à cette relation
mais je crois que fondamentalement et la
question identité à perdre utile et je
bosse plus et oui et je crois parce que
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y as on a
train de se fixer sur la relation on a
la france on sait qu'on est français
mais qu'on est aussi martiniquais je
crois que de plus en plus dans la
conscience martiniquaise on a cette
relation s'est alors ça peut paraître de
la schizophrénie qu'au vu de l'extérieur
mais nous nous savons que par exemple
qu'on te dit je vais en france on sait
très bien qu'on a en france quelqu'un
qui habite dans l'hexagone ne comprend
pas ce qu'on lui dit qu'on dit je vends
la france mais nous on sait très bien ce
qu'on dit nous et vous oubliez les gens
qui habitent ici depuis longtemps ils le
savent
et ça ne serait ce que dans cette
expression je crois qu'on a résumé la
relation du martiniquais avec la france
voilà c'est sur ces mots que se termine
notre émission qui aurait pu se
prolonger ou of 4 5 heures le plus ce
n'est pas avec marc ses fils que vous
venez d'entendre et le professeur jean
claude williams met ainsi monsieur
d'avoir participé en est à 7
cette émission face à la première aussi
à la vie et la mort du département
émission réalisée aujourd'hui par paul
eric toussaint que vous pouvez retrouver
en podcast sur notre site internet la
première point fr et pour en savoir plus
si vous pouvez aller je pense qu'en
librairie ou en tout cas en bibliothèque
retrouver l'homme livre de marc ses fils
évolution institutionnelle et politique
des antilles le cas de la martinique
chez ibis rouge publiée en 2003 mais
aussi à bientôt
face à la première
[Musique]